[Musique]
donc si j'ai bien compris on va par
groupes de sept ou huit partis légaux de
huit puisque plus le guide
[Musique]
chanter
bonjour je m'appelle phoenix irlandaise
votre guide aujourd'hui c'est vrai mais
si vous pouvez vous être mieux aussi
et pour ça peut nous aider de connaître
les événements et quel pays d'où vous
venez
je m'appelle bernard je suis français
soyez très content d'être ici
daniel je suis breton
les spas du mp de passe
cela dit des bêtises et minimiser à
dominante
le big boss a relevé de familles estime
jan steen strom un style continue to
fight un petit peu ému c'est bien vous
bah oui c'est quelque chose ça fait 35
ans pour après j'avais vu j'avais vu
comme je travaillais au gabon à l'époque
il ya 35 ans j'avais vu furtivement un
gorille dans le fond de la forêt
et puis je m'étais dit que j'aimerais
bien me rapprocher un peu plus de 7 de
cette bête fantastique et voilà c'est
aujourd'hui super puce ou de maladies
notamment la gr d'accord
[Musique]
daniel tu me vois là là ça va parce que
vous n'auriez pas très gros lot par
contre avec un plus gros qui bouge
[Musique]
cela me coûtait la marraine moyenne fois
mon hôtel une erreur une fois bon
oui mais viennent de me dire déjà qu'ils
ont déjà les autres déjà trouvé le
gorille saut avec les gorilles
alors je me dis qu'on va monter au va
s'appeler les chemins des sabines c'est
là haut ils sont avec les gorilles à
manger je veux pas utiliser flash
puisque avec la lumière ça effraie les
allégories ça veut dire pas beau
d'utiliser le flash et pour les visites
aux gorilles et ambassadeur nous
plaindre inédite a elle aussi à
l'épreuve au coup d'état alors ça il
changer leurs comportements commencent à
être agressif quand vous voulez éternuer
vous devez toujours fait comme ça c'est
pour éviter la propagation des d'être à
transmission des maladies humaines
c'est pour cela que on a toujours fait
comme ça
c'est que ce soit mais alors avec les
yeux montage je me sens jeune et sans
une approche un peu long quand même
assez bien c'est bien ça nous laisse le
temps de faire monter la pression et le
plaisir sera à la hauteur de la tente
alors ça me devient insupportable ces
dernières minutes d'attentes
là ça fait deux heures qu'on marge mais
on sait qu'ils sont là il reste quelques
minutes
donc c'est maintenant
[Musique]
l'impression qu'ils nous attendent et
pousser l'avion pour nous regarder
c'était mon extraordinaire de savoir si
près
[Musique]
j'ai qu'ils vont gratter levante a tué
avec des grosses plus rien faire
[Musique]
tous
comment tu dis encore il est l'heure de
te lever contraignant à atteindre une
assiette pas sa volonté
vous voyez donné les passages sur la
sensation station
tiens
demain devant il ya derrière vincent il
a donné une baffe à son copain je
préfère qu'il est de nassau copains qui
aboie notre présence les indiffère
visiblement et vaquaient à leurs
occupations on est autour nous ont
intégré au paysage
on les dérange peau mais ils s'en
foutent c'est très bien quand ça
commence à prendre et les dernières
photos les presque pas ok merci beaucoup
pour tout le monde de venir visiter les
gorilles est ici au rwanda je suis
vraiment impressionné par le naturel de
la relation entre entre l'animal et nous
et je suppose que c'est du un gros
travail de tous ces gens là de la
conservation on habitue des animaux à
nous avoir droit le paysage et nous ça
nous permet de profiter qui est
impressionnant quand même et ça j'en
étais pas sûr avant de les voir si
j'avais peur d'avoir peur et en fait on
est tout près d'eux et arrière on n'a
jamais eu peur à aucun moment tellement
les son paisible du gentil fait partie
du paysage depuis ronde et là on les
regarde et ça c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire espèce de confiance qui
lie entre nous et
[Musique]
les clients au rwanda viennent
principalement cherché de la nature des
grands espaces et la faune
donc en fait on essaye au travers de
visites régulières comme celles ci au
rwanda de valider que ce contrat mais
quelque part à nos clients on va pouvoir
leur fournir et leur servir
donc ça ne tarde loges qui a la
particularité d'être un coin très isolés
très excentré cedar loges qui est tout
petit plutôt haut de gamme est paraît-il
avec une vue merveilleuse sur les deux
lacs qui sont derrière moi
enchantée et franck enchanté
arrêt le soir ça un drôle vous faites
cas je vis en plus sale du pour le soir
tranquille
le ciss dr traoré comme ça mais le
d'accord bas où ils sont nés à 2500
mètres donc il fait quand même cher
frère mais mais là le c'est vrai que ce
qu'on a on est à l'est du parc des
volcans
le matin ça doit aller avec le lever du
jour ça doit être extraordinaire c'est
quand même vraiment spectaculaire quand
même waouh ah ouais ouais c'est sympa
c'est vraiment je comprends mieux
effectivement là le prix on va essayer
d'y faire venir des des français je vais
m'en occuper
je vais essayer
[Musique]
bonjour très très bien et vous même ce
beau soleil
merci beaucoup la santé
il faut mieux si on a le choix
s'intéresser à des logs comme celui-ci
qui a des logs totalement privées voire
étrangers là au moins on a en plus une
action qui va qui va en faveur de la
population et c'est vrai que ne serait
ce que pour ça ça vaut ça vaut le coup
ou futilement d'accepter on va dire une
certaine rusticité du lieu que c'est pas
du grand confort on n'est pas dans du
haut de gamme mais en tout cas pour
passer une ou deux nuits
c'est tout à fait plaisant et en tout
cas les gens sont en l'air charmant donc
ça ce sont des terrains qui
appartiennent à sauter voilà
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
100 des des white people can say a
besoin bring him and we are very happy
défi things to show à bordeaux aïcha
bête semaine impôts des non membres avec
le tag est défait ce stage est restée
célèbre i talk héritiers de ceux qui
savent atomique manioc gosse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je connais beaucoup 18 m
nous avons en tout cas de la frontière
commune apporte des nouveautés dans le
café on voit la direction de désherber
ici et puis on voit qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui est passé par là et heureusement
mais ya un piège si c'est dangereux
aussi pour le gorille toutes les pièges
sont dangereux pour osciller gorille
puisque souvent qu'à un gorille et passe
par six ans à le savoir
il met directement les blagues vous
savez qu'il marche comme ça marche comme
ça et filmé le bla là bas il est
rattrapé par le piégeux direct où il met
la pâte la basse à savoir
[Musique]
ça ne montre qu'il ya un piège puisque
ça c'est ça ça montre un pied de biche
c'est comme ça que les braconniers
cacher les pièges de dire oui et ça ça
peut être très dangereux pour les
gorilles
ça c'est très dangereux pour les
gorilles cas le gorille états amis les
blindés daou donc la pâte
il utilise les autres viennent il y
tueur
quant au futur c'est très dangereux
puisqu'il ya régulier qui roule donc les
blast ont cassé les jambes sont cassées
à cause de ce piège mais tariq
il va prendre les coordonnées gps pour
voir là où l'endroit qui est très très
critique pour un piège à fait qu'on
puisse se prendre des mesures de
contrôle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
un attaquant de nice hugo séguin faisait
qui un temps voiture n'est prête aux
banques
[Musique]
ça c'est là que la qui l'habitent
n'est pas très content acquis morts je
suis fière problème parce que pour moi
je l'aimé gsm et diane fossey
oui je les aime parce que l enseignement
pour la pale ale un grégory make him or
je n'ai pas très content
[Musique]
sur des directives des portes avec
williams à l'interaction radio j
[Musique]
je pense mais où est passé le losc du
single
après mon père est simple il doit me
lassais alors assez bed-in cuistot album
selon la présidente a été à seconde des
différentes groupe et tout y est
individuelle de groupe id les cercles et
un individu et al sour file comme
l'indiquent actionner des sexes et de
classe des coins de nature de l'anneau
et il a quoi sa plus importante depuis
celle disegno de l'im pro ana sara lee
kuan de louhans cuiseaux kasuga can't
beat et que ce design représente ta
propre il saigne au kernel nassau ville
ou en résine qui avait pas une asso
mojito caractéristiques offertes la
précense adéquiste o senio qui on y va
et les d'où est partie supérieure et
inférieure et qui pouvait décliner la
faute pour qui l'amour te fâcher les
individus à la déco arts à paris pour
tromperie mortelle de 1000 nm sera lost
et 100 m dos comme ça va d'ailleurs
forcé et pando un habitué de ce groupe
figure il perd identification et léo m
dos à toile estime que l'on est encore
aux amours identifie catégorie
y at il de nos bêtes sauvages ou du
compost qui sont nôtres telment et non
activée une décision dénoncée
sir kutxa notion qui comprend de la
pieuvre et notamment l'équilibré
ça m'arrive a été aussitôt donnée de
queen queen l'ordre à ne pas s'être la
note
calama
ok a bien encore parce que corinne
laquelle emma stone et d'autres clients
collation une partie colère et celle de
l'essai mais il est quand même encore au
piccolo csb lianhai schiste à bordeaux
et sur l'eau qu'un corps anonymes ont
assez brutaux diallo
didier yo affolant include idole en
paquet de coller le bout des incendies
des étapes lui même dont ils identiques
aux portables
cali c'est wayne rooney comme diego
contento carrasso est à fait me la coule
ou die et le train de l'est at-il ita
des cours d'eau dit on et d'y acheminer
aux ti et 7e comportementaux spécifique
oui ça m'intéresse à atik et qui a bien
aimé la plastie maroc où nous séduire
acosta féminine est louée logiciels à
tout y était les comportements finita
cours d'initiation au nigeria
[Musique]
centro de ténis à mégoter de la
confiscation des sonos agorila la
catégorie la sonader gorille de la
confiscation des braconniers a dit
qu'ils aimeraient bien montrer son quad
qu'à nous faire rêver les mollets
consiste à répéter faire une liste des
reliques saleh a reçu ce titre de la
marque il a co sinon non libanais à
moteur original l'euro et ne les auriez
des séropos linda lê thi thu mind the
right to play
qu il arrive à nos statuts horrible et
de billy tati et physiquement et
psychologiquement c'est en quelques
longueurs et la précieuse dalle et dale
sont bientôt nature à aller à sécurité
subito lucci zone est de la madre parce
que la madone permettrait bernis ou non
du plan d'eau est possible un tel outil
zone et des altitudes et le groupe
clouseau il
il masque dominante et sa part l'arrêt
pourrait de facto qui préfigurait la
vivons une percée timani d'intro et
picoler gaby est malnutri d'image draka
a dit
[Musique]
là